fliegerhorst aigen im ennstal früher
morgen bei dieser nebel lage ist an
hubschrauberflüge normalerweise gar
nicht zu denken
wer hier stationiert ist weiß allerdings
dass sich der nebel im laufe des
vormittags zur gänze auflösen wird
deshalb werden vier alu at drei
helikopter des bundesheers aus dem
hangar geholt und flug fertig gemacht
[Musik]
heute steuern 3 nachwuchspiloten auf den
sogenannten höhepunkt in ihrer
ausbildung zum einsatz piloten zu
die hochgebirgs landen ziel der
ausbildung ist des hochgebirges
landungen durchzuführen das heißt dass
ist die letzte stufe bevor er zum
einsatz minuten wird hochgebirgs
landungen sind an sich die schwierigste
phase der ausbildung da es sich im
höhen ab 2.500 meter abspielt wo wir
wenig gegen die landeplätze haben es
sehr schwierig ist die entsprechenden
wind situationen zu berechnen ebenfalls
rasch wechselndes wetter starke
wettereinflüsse und somit wird jede
landung im hochgebirge auch bei schönem
wetter wie heute zu einer nicht
gefährlich aber zu einer kritischen
situation
und gerade deswegen müssen wir vermehrt
diese landungen auch im hochgebirge
trainieren um unsere österreichischen
ohne seine piloten dementsprechend gut
ausgewiesen zu haben
die drei einsatzpiloten in ausbildung
die heute ihre ersten hochgebirgs
landungen durchführen werden sind
richard lucas und friedrich sie alle
verbindet natürlich die liebe zur
fliegerei so eine leidenschaft entsteht
meist in frühster jugend also darum in
schubladen zu werden hat sie jetzt vor
allem den letzten drei jahren sehr stark
entwickelt man bisher mit der 16 17
immer noch mal dann gekommen dass das
eigentlich das fliegen an sich als beruf
sehr coole sache wäre das war eigentlich
immer schon ein kindheitstraum das her
hat man dann die möglichkeit geben dazu
und wir dann ergriffen weil es eben sehr
ein sehr fordernder schöner beruf ist
überlegt man sich dann halt schon was
wird man gern machen und da war dann
pilot sein so dass ich mir ausgesucht
hat und was dann also aufgaben und habe
das dann eben der bundesrepublik und ist
mir zum glück gelungen
obwohl bei den heutigen ausbildungsflüge
nahezu kaiserwetter herrschte sind
hochgebirgs landungen alles andere als
einfach so darf man sich nicht täuschen
lassen weil trotzdem der wind wahrheit
nicht ohne
also freuen über 2000 meter wo man dann
nicht schon richtig viel winterware aus
verschiedensten richtungen kommt im
gebirge das heißt man muss da trotzdem
die zeit nehmen das mit dem platz genau
erkundet und schaut woher der wind genau
kommt damit ihrem anflug von so
hinbringen der freifläche ohne viel
kopiert das gelände mit wenig wind das
natürlich sehr leicht und je mehr dass
es jetzt ins gebirge geht ist es
leistungsmäßig natürlich fordernd
beziehungsweise wind mäßig bei sehr viel
abrisskanten gibt und das gelände
natürlich sehr viel schwieriger ist also
alles was gebirges ist quasi schon ganz
schwer das war unterschied zum flachland
ist das einfach die situation ganz
anders ist sie wird unberechenbar und
wenn man dort immer ein ausweg hat dann
muss man sie hat fünf überlegen wo man
da wirklich hin entdeckt und waren hat
jetzt heute schon stellen dabei die es
in meinem ausbildung stand jetzt so
nicht angeflogen und das aber
interessant zu sehen wenn man ist eben
richtig beurteilt das ist trotzdem
möglich ist dass martin endlich ein
richtiger entscheidungen im künftigen
einsätzen treffen zu können sind diese
ausbildungsflüge unerlässlich
wir haben gesehen durch diese
schneekatastrophe dass es sehr wichtig
ist gerade in solchen situationen rasche
hilfe zur bevölkerung bringen zu können
das erreichen wir nur mit gut
ausgebildeten piloten und der weiß
natürlich genau worauf es bei einem
landeanflug wirklich an dass man am
konstanten geklärt was achten darauf
dass man die windsituation
beziehungsweise die hindernis situation
ein held dass man sie sicherheiten
schafften mit fluchtwegen und dass man
geschwindigkeiten im anflug beibehält
beziehungsweise dann einfach richtige
entscheidungen trifft und um die
richtige entscheidung treffen zu können
gehört auch die kenntnis des geländes
dazu sollten das noch mal da haben wir
unter montag steine flogen
da muss man sie nicht darauf
konzentrieren dass man das land hat
sondern man schaut ja die gegend am
rande des motor hin muss und das kann
man dann auch mal genießen weil man
nicht innerhalb von den nächsten zwei
minuten prozent
[Musik]
nach erfolgreicher absolvierung des
hochgebirgsland kurses werden richard
lucas und friedrich einsatzpiloten
werden die aus und weiterbildung endet
aber nie es ist nicht so dass man sagen
kann es ist jetzt abgeschlossen und
fertig weil man ständig was neues dazu
lernen und lehrgangs kommandant
oberleutnant alexander handel ist mit
der entwicklung der jungen piloten
sichtlich zufrieden die schüler
entwickelt sich prächtig und somit bin
ich derzeit mit den ausbildungserfolg
voll und ganz zufrieden
[Musik]